oil giant saudi aramco has seen a
25 drop in profits for the first quarter
of this year and warns of
challenging conditions for the months
ahead among its concerns production
[ __ ]
saudi arabia's energy ministry announced
monday it would deepen its cuts by
a further 1 million barrels per day as
global demand weakens
now this is a blow for one of the
world's biggest companies
the world was a very different place
last december when saudi aramco
the biggest oil company of them all went
public in a blaze of glitz
the coronavirus pandemic means the bell
has well and truly told for the oil
sector
even for a company then valued at a
mind-boggling 1.7 trillion dollars
the pandemic has quickly burned through
balance sheets
the price of crude oil has plunged
dramatically since coronavirus lockdowns
led to a massive reduction in demand in
the six months since aramco launched its
shares
oil has lost well over half its value on
global markets
saudi aramco has already felt the impact
of that
its stock price has been in steady
decline since the ipo
yet so far it has not fallen anywhere
near as sharply as the overall price of
oil
that may be because the company still
plans on paying out a 25 billion dollar
dividend for the next five years
however in what looks an increasingly
barren time for the sector
all bets are off in the oil kingdom
okay are any bets on for more let's find
out from claudia camford energy expert
at the german institute for economic
research good morning claudia nice to
see you when it comes to
when it comes to saudi aramco there it's
problems
are they strictly a result of the virus
hitting the demand for
oil or do they predate the crisis
well i would say it's predating the
crisis because
we already saw before the corona crisis
extended that there are severe
difficulties
not only in saudi arabia but especially
to saudi aramco
so the stakeholders are basically
domestic
there are geopolitical risks there's a
corruption and a lot of uncertainty
so even now with the corona crisis the
problems are increasing all the
challengings
the challenges are increasing so we now
are facing a difficult situation
okay it's a challenge is not just for
oil companies like
aramco the entire oil-based saudi
arabian
economy is in a position that was
absolutely unimaginable
last quarter can riyadh get out of this
crisis
well only if they do a lot of reforms
and only if
they are changing also their their
business models for the whole country
because they are now very dependent on
oil
and gas experts they need an oil price
above a level of 70
per barrel and this is the price we will
not see
this year even not next year if if the
oil demand is still low and therefore
they need to
change they need to invest more into
renewables into energy saving programs
into reforms like increasing taxes and
all this
it's unlikely that this will happen so
fast so they
might come severe difficulty or a
severely difficult time
okay and that that raises all sorts of
stability issues for that entire region
let's move on to a very
a startling statement by the ceo of oil
company bp he's saying it's possible
that we've reached peak oil that demand
might fail to pick up
after the coronavirus crisis how can the
oil
industry continue in its current form
well yeah i i i mean it's very difficult
that they are
continuing in this current form they
need to structure they need to
restructure and also invest into
alternatives to
oil because the oil era is ending now
with the corona crisis even faster than
expected
so the oil demand might might be low
only because
the flights are decreasing the economic
stimulus
program in many oecd countries are
fostering
cleaner technologies like electric
mobility
and also the heating system which are
replaced
and the insulation is boosted
by this kind of program so the oil
demand might be low so the companies
need to change
and also diversify also to
more renewable energy and also change
their supply structure
okay so there could be a golden lining
to this crisis for
renewables uh claudia thank you very
much for coming in on this today
thank you
well eu health ministers are meeting
today to discuss the virus's impact on
the production and
distribution of medicines the pandemic
continues to wreak havoc on
international supply chains many of the
components of common medications
come from china and then move on to
secondary countries so
what happens when productions of the raw
materials stops
let's take a look it's loud in here
stuffy and smelly manufacturing
antibiotics is a dirty process and back
in march
production at penham laboratories near
delhi was going full blast
churning out 150 tons a month
the final product goes to 60 countries
including some in europe
where it's pressed into pill form but
the precursor substances come from china
and the coronavirus shut down there
threatened production here
it just shows how utterly dependent the
world is
eighty percent of medicinal raw
materials come from china
india used to produce them too but
chinese products are cheaper
china has been in last 25-30 years
seen that rest of the world stops
manufacturing
and many of the advanced countries
they have forgotten the art of
manufacturing antibiotics
they thought that's the ugly thing to
make dirty their hands
so they passed on basically to china
in germany pharmacists like here near
stuttgart were having to apologize to
customers about supply problems
shortages of key painkillers and blood
pressure drugs as well as antibiotics
were already an issue even before
germany went into lockdown
once china stopped exporting things look
to go from bad to worse
but global supply chains for medicines
are complex and non-transparent
if you're a manufacturer of course
you're not going to say where you get
your substances
at what price and in what volume it's
like in other industries
how you get your raw materials can give
you a competitive edge
the coronavirus crisis has only
highlighted what experts have long
warned about
pricing pressure especially for generic
medications has led to massive
dependence on china
many pharmacists in germany would like
to see at least part of the production
process brought back home
where can this end we need the
manufacturers to ensure stable supplies
it cannot go on like this we really have
to bring production back to germany to
europe
and with similar calls being made in
india it could mean governments will
take new steps to break the chinese
dominance of the pharmaceuticals market
well german industrial giant tyson krupp
is reporting a 1.3
billion euro loss as it struggles to
deal with the fallout
from the pandemic the company which has
already let go of 3 000
employees and the steel division is
facing a growing mountain of debt and
that is
eating into the cash generated from a
multi-billion euro sale
of its elevator business
let's get more on this with dw's markets
reporter
chelsea delaney down in frankfurt for us
good morning to you chelsea
um tissenkrupp was in the middle of a
deep reform plan when all of this hit
the bad news will this
derail those reform efforts
this is certainly a blow to these uh
these turnaround plans which were
seen as extremely crucial for disencrypt
[ __ ] after years of
seeing their business shrink after
seeing their market value decline
uh the the key part of this was they
were going to sell this elevator unit
for about 17 billion euros and then use
all of that money to reinvest in their
business
and to pay down some of that debt but
now that they're facing a huge drop off
in in demand particularly for their auto
part business
they're saying that this is really going
to eat into the money that they have to
reinvest to pay down debt
and this is really spooking shareholders
today the the stock opened
down in frankfort about seven percent
also
spooking shareholders profits at the
french train maker alstom
they're also down will the pressure now
ease on that comp company and for the
sector
now that we're seeing some economies
starting
to reopen
well al stems is sounding quite
optimistic today
they say that they're starting to
restart production in their factories
that
they expect that to to really ramp up
over the next couple of
a couple of months but they are seeing a
really significant
decline in demand because they they
supply trains
demand for for train travel has been
quite low and all of the the train
companies are really struggling so
they do say that this could impact their
their results for the for this year
uh for the 2021-2020 uh fiscal year but
they they do expect the the market to
turn around
uh quite soon they are for one really
confident and the the train
market because um this is really seen as
the the
the key uh transportation um
this is really going to be a very
important transportation source going
forward
into this era of green mobility good to
hear that there's a note of optimism
in frankfurt today in spite of all the
the bloodletting out there chelsea
thanks for that